so you've worked with a lot of young
students and I'm curious what the the
idea in their minds of what it's like
out in the real world is versus what the
real world is like in terms of whether
they were the two best writers in the
whole class well I think you know when I
teach a class that UCLA are my private
workshops there's all these people that
just want to be professional writers I
have no idea what it's like to be a
professional writer and I don't think
you ever know until you do it and so
it's just I want to be a professional
writer and I have a vision of what that
would be I think most people's vision is
I sit in a room or in a room with other
people but let's say I sit in a room and
I write what I want to write and I write
it in a way that I want to write it and
I write what I love and everyone else
will love it
it don't work family people have a
process to how they write in that
process usually is what's comfortable
because it plays their strengths and has
of weaknesses and it's learning how to
write in a way that other people love it
as much as you love it and it takes a
lot of work and a lot of training and
then there's deadlines and there's
politics it's there's a lot that goes
into having a writing career beyond just
the writing I mean the reality was like
you have two careers you have the
writing you know you have you have to
create the content but then there's the
career management and the meetings and
the marketing and always be looking for
your other job there's a lot that goes
into it but at the same time I mean to
get paid and to be able to make a living
playing with characters and playing with
stories and and doing something that
especially if it's creatively fulfilling
and you get paid for it
you know for people who do it right and
train themselves the right way they
literally do something that they would
do for free and they get paid and
perhaps they get paid millions of
dollars perhaps they get paid tens of
million dollars perhaps they get paid
hundreds of thousand dollars tops they
get paid a hundred thousand dollars to
do what you would do for free that
actually is possible and I have a
growing list of clients and students who
have that lifestyle so I think anyone
who really is drawn to this
should absolutely pursue it you know and
just pursue it in the right ways we
talked about though the beginning stages
of their career where a lot of its going
to rest on discipline and being your own
taskmaster and I think it's easy when
you think okay I have to you know get
back to this person's email on do I have
this vintage and write finish but when
in the beginning is going to be a lot of
time alone right there's going to be a
lot of time being your own task writer
and how difficult that is yeah so it is
really difficult in the beginning and a
lot of writers have this fantasy or this
illusion and I did and I was wrong is
that you know you're you're working and
you're making money and you know and
you're trying to write and you're so
busy and writing so hard and it god when
you sell something and when you get
hired then you don't you can quit your
day job and you can quit this you can
just write an oh what a luxury that
would be because you're so time starved
but when you first break like when I
first broke in the business you know I
had two months to write the script for
metropolis but almost every day I had
meetings and I had to go in meetings and
I was talking about other projects and
pitching and it I actually was spending
more time on that than I was on my day
job so I actually had less time to write
and you would just pulled in so many
directions and so discipline really
matters so one of the things that I
teach writers from the very beginning
non writers who are starting out and
then the what and a lot of them won't do
this but the ones that do not only do
they become better writers this will
save their rear ends when they have a
career is I teach them the idea of a
writer schedule so what that means is if
you have a job that pays the bills in
Thursday at 3 o'clock you have to do a
marketing proposal to your boss I know
where you're going to be Thursday at 3
o'clock you're going to be doing that
proposal if you don't feel like it and
you don't like to Fogle's that good
you're still going to do the best you
can and if you feel like watching TV or
you're napping you're going to be there
or you're not going to have a job and
you know from 10 a.m. to 12 p.m. you are
supposed to meet with this client you're
going to do that and you schedule your
life around that so what I tell people
is no one is going to treat you like the
professional
until you are a professional no one's
going to invest money in you until you
put the money where your mouth is so you
have a career perhaps you have a family
perhaps you have all of these poles on
your time I get that every Sunday night
you're going to create a writer schedule
for the next week and maybe you can only
write 45 minutes a day ideally an hour
or two hours let's say 90 minutes a day
you will block out that writing time be
it at 7:30 in the morning be it at six
o'clock whatever it is for every day for
that week now if you've blocked out
Thursday from 7:30 to 8:30 is your
writing time I know we're going to be at
7:30 you're going to be writing and it's
not if you feel like it because that's
like your marketing meeting with your
boss so you schedule out your writing
time every single week and then you
honor that and if you're not willing to
do that and you're not willing to honor
that why should anyone else invest money
in you
you